It's important to point out that
when we say reinforcement learning,
we're really describing a problem,
not a solution.
In the same way that linear regression
is one solution to the supervised
regression problem, there are many
algorithms that solve the RL problem.
Because I started out as a roboticists,
I'm going to first explain this in
terms of a problem for a robot.
So here's our robot here and
our robot is going to interact
with the environment.
So we represent the environment
as this sort of cloud up here.
So the robots going to take actions
that'll change the environment.
It will sense the environment,
reason over what it sees and
take another action.
In robotics, we call this the sense,
think, act cycle and
you don't have to implement it
only using reinforcement learning.
There's many ways that you could
implement sense, think, act, but
we're going to focus on how to do
that with reinforcement learning.
Okay, so
our robot observes the environment and
some form of description of
the environment comes in.
Let's call that the state s, so
s is our letter that represents
what we see in the environment.
Now the robot has to process that
state somehow to determine what to do.
And we call this pi or
policy, so the robot
takes in the state s and
then outputs an action.
We'll call that action a and
it affects the environment
in some way and changes it.
Now this is a sort of circular process,
the action a is taken
into the environment and the environment
then transitions to a new state.
So T is this transition
function that takes in
what its previous state was and
the action and moves to a new state.
And that new state comes out,
boom, back into the robot.
Robot looks at his policy,
action comes out.
Now there's a question,
how do we arrive at this policy?
How do we find pi?
Well, that's what we're going to
spend a couple lessons on, but
this whole puzzle is missing a piece and
that's the thing that helps us find pi.
And part of that piece is well,
there's this other part
called r which is the reward.
So everytime the robot is in a
particular state and it takes an action.
There's a particular reward associated
with taking that action in that state
and that reward comes into the robot.
And you can think of
the robot has having a little
pocket where it keeps cash and
that's what that reward is.
And the robot's objective is,
over time, to take actions
that maximize this reward.
And somewhere within the robot,
there's an algorithm that takes all this
information over time to figure
out what that policy ought to be.
So let me recap a little bit.
S is the state of our environment and
that's what the robot senses
in order to decide what to do.
It uses its policy pi to figure
out what that action should be.
And by the way,
pi can be a simple look up table.
Over time, each time the robot takes
an action, it gets a reward and
it's trying to find the pi that
will maximize its reward over time.
Now in terms of trading, our environment
really is the market and our actions
are actions we can take in the market,
like buying and selling or holding.
S are factors about our stocks that
we might observe and know about.
And r is the return we get for
making the proper trades.